bitcoin is the Internet of money and I
say that bitcoin is the internet of
money not because bitcoin in and of
itself is the internet but because
Bitcoin empowers for the idea of money
what the internet was able to do with
information and in doing that it gives
any person in the world the ability to
quantify create store and share the idea
of value in a way that we as a human
race have never really been able to do
before and bitcoin is - blockchain as
email is - the Internet it is the first
major use case of a technology that is
so fundamentally going to change the way
that we think about our everyday life
that it will transform every interaction
we have from inception on blockchain is
called the blockchain because it's
literally just that it is a series of
blocks created by computer solving
complex math problems that are chained
together and the way that bitcoin is
created is anytime one of these blocks
like imagine you just have a bunch of
sheets of paper and anytime one of the
sheets of paper gets full a bunch of
supercomputers from all around the world
are all trying to solve these insanely
complex math problems that get
exponentially more difficult over time
and to give you perspective it's
literally easier to find one grain of
sand in the entire universe than it is
for one of these computers to solve a
math problem created by the Bitcoin
blockchain and because these are so
complex and because any time one of
these little computers tries to solve
one of these problems they only have a
50/50 chance of getting it right no
matter how many times they try and solve
it and so Bitcoin right now is actually
the world's largest supercomputer it has
500 times the computing power of Google
just to create bitcoins
now anytime one of these computers
solves a math problem they get Bitcoin
they create the block cement it and
these blocks are all chained together in
one long ring and that has a Genesis
block and is essentially infinite from
the moment the first block on the
blockchain was created and every
transaction that happens on the
blockchain is stored on the blockchain
cannot be erased cannot be deleted
because the core properties of this
technology are fundamentally that a
blockchain is borderless it is
decentralized it is voluntary and it is
immutable Bitcoin is and always has been
a research project and that's what's so
amazing I mean it was created by this
group of you know underground
libertarians and activists and
anarchists whose roles in life were to
beat death and taxes and Bitcoin is
something that has actually been you
know in these forums for the last 40
years and it's really interesting
because you have these people who
essentially see the flaws in every
system that exists in the world today
and I would actually say that Bitcoin is
very similar to Burning Man in the way
that it's created and the way that it's
going to grow and the way that it's
going to evolve because what is Burning
Man the festival the experience the
culture the civilization what is that
other than the world's most evolved form
of Anarchy Burning Man in the 70s were
literally a bunch of awesome cool
anarchists going into the desert and
shooting guns which isn't necessarily
safe but shooting guns into the middle
of the sky and literally burning down
the man and you see
happens when you allow people to fulfill
their ultimate creative potential people
become autonomous self-reliant and they
self organize and that's actually how I
would say the evolution of Bitcoin to
contextualize it in something that's
extremely modern and extremely well
known Bitcoin and the idea of value and
money I believe will follow a very
similar path because what it actually
does and enables as well is for the
creative economy to flourish because all
of these jobs that are going to be
replaced by AI where are people gonna
get money from and I fundamentally
believe that they will create it
literally anytime you have this kind of
a revolutionary idea in culture form
they're always going to be people who
have to adapt and who have to change and
the people who have the greatest
adaptation to wrap their minds around
our fundamentally institutions who have
built a business model off of
third-party trust because what the
blockchain actually does it takes that
idea of trust
it's a trustless system and when I say
that some people are like so like
there's trust the system less than
normal systems no it means the idea of
trust in and of itself is a concept that
we have based off of institutional
integrity and if you are an institution
with integrity generally I would say you
don't have anything to worry about
but people who have been abusing systems
that have been in place for centuries
those people are going to be and and
everyone knows that they need to change
and that they need to be held
accountable but because there are so
many issues that are just systemically
entrenched
you have to create something new I think
to really really shift that paradigm and
I wouldn't say that a lot of these
institutions who are built on
third-party trust it's like they're not
gonna completely disappear it's just
like when we had the Internet the idea
of publishing didn't go away it just
fundamentally evolved in a way that
empowered the individual to create their
own content and empowered groups of
people to self-organize and to create
their own worlds and their own
publishing models from this invention
that fundamentally not only democratized
and distributed but decentralized the
way that we were able to create and to
share and to consume information and so
in addition to that the way that people
will actually be able to create this
form of value is incredible it's
something I think a lot of people even
today have a hard time imagining because
it's like telling people in the
Renaissance hey so you know all of that
information owned by God one day you
will not only be able to have access to
it you will not only be able to share it
openly and freely but you will be able
to create that yourself and that is what
is about to happen with the idea of
money and the idea of value and to give
you a really concrete example of
something that's an emergent technology
that might just be an economic
experiment right a lot of these things
in the market right now are just
economic experiments but there's a
platform called steam it steam with two
e's and it fundamentally is a monetized
Reddit and it allows any person who
creates content to be directly
compensated by a group of their peers
for the content they create so imagine
if every upvote on reddit
was monetized and I mean I did one post
on this and made $3,000 that I could
exchange immediately in 50 minutes and
that's incredible I still don't think
most people understand what is about to
emerge in this modern technology
landscape and it's fundamentally the
ability for any person to create a
platform and if that platform has value
whether that value is in the content
whether that value is in the community
to aggregate new systems of creating
sharing and storing value and to
quantify those using a digital currency